字幕: Mitsumasa Mito
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
皆さん お寺は好きですか
（笑）
いや失礼しました
突然お寺が好きかって聞かれて
好きですって即答できる方は
なかなかいらっしゃいませんよね
それに そもそも
お寺が好きかどうか自体
あまり聞かれることがないと思います
でもなかには お寺が好きだよって方は
いらっしゃるんじゃないでしょうか
例えばお寺の古い時代の仏像や
日本庭園なんかは
日本人だけでなく外国の方の中にも
大好きだよって方が
結構いらっしゃると思います
実は日本には全国で７万７千もの数の
お寺があると言われています
日本のコンビニの総数が
５万７千店と言われていますから
それよりも２万も多いんですから
どれだけお寺の数が多いか
ということが分かりますよね
でも コンビニは週に何回か
中には毎日行くよって方も
いらっしゃると思うんですが
お寺はどうですか
週一？
いやいや 月に一度だって
お寺に行くよという方は
あまりいらっしゃらないんじゃ
ないでしょうかね
近くて遠い存在
それが今のお寺なんだと思います
そもそも好きかどうか以前に
皆さんにとってお寺という場所
亡くなった方のお墓参りや
法事で行くことが多い
つまり あまり楽しく行く場所では
ありませんよね
でも最近は 楽しく行けちゃうお寺
少しずつですが増え始めています
例えば このうちのお寺
法多山尊永寺と言いますが
うちのお寺もそのひとつです
実は今夜も「星満夜（ほしみつよ）」という
秋の夜を楽しむイベントが行われます
秋の虫の声を聞きながら
満天の星空を眺めたり
大きな天体望遠鏡で
星雲や惑星を鑑賞する
とっても素敵なイベントじゃありませんか
でもこのイベント
私たちお寺の力だけで できるわけではなく
アマチュアの天文家の方や
多くの市民の皆さんのご協力をいただいて
初めてできるイベントなんです
それ以外にもほぼ一年中
何かしらのイベントが行われている ―
豊かな自然の中にあって
大変活気に満ちたお寺です
ではなぜ 私がこうした取り組みを
しているのか
別にたくさんイベントをしなくても
十分お寺自体は成り立っているんですが
それでもなぜこうした取り組みを
しているのか
理由は２つです
１つ目の理由
それは
人々が集い にぎわい 楽しい場所
それがお寺の本来あるべき姿だと
私が信じているからです
かつてのお寺
そう100年ほど前のお寺は
今の私たちが持っている
お寺のイメージとは全然違ったんです
かつてのお寺
特に地方のお寺は
そこの地域コミュニティの拠り所だったんです
例えば 寺子屋という言葉が示すように
かつてのお寺は そこに住む人々の
学びの場でもありました
また田舎の村で市場が建つといえば
お寺の門前でありましたし
寄合いや会合といえば
お寺のお堂や建物を借りて
行われることが多かったようです
このように かつてのお寺は
人々の集いの場でもありました
また 子どもの遊び場といえば
お寺の境内
地方巡業の芝居小屋がかかるのも
お寺の中であることが多かったようですし
それ以外にも さまざまな娯楽の場として
お寺は用いられてきました
かつてのお寺は
人々の遊びの場でもあったんです
時代が下り こうした機能は
学校やコミュニティセンター
あるいは娯楽施設に移されてきました
今のお寺は亡くなった方のための場所
お寺の仕事も
亡くなった方の霊を弔い
お祀りすることがもっぱらだと
思ってらっしゃる方が多いと思います
お坊さんの中にさえ そうした
認識の方がたくさんいらっしゃいます
もちろん それはそれで
とても大切なことなんですが
かつてあった機能を放棄し続ける必要を
私は感じません
むしろ 本来あるべきお寺の姿を取り戻し
今のお寺に融合した方が
仏様の教えを広げるのに役に立つ
そう私は考えているんです
２つ目の理由
それはこうした活動を通して
多くの仲間に巡り合い
なにかをつくる楽しみ
時には苦しみを
いや もしかしたら その苦しみも
楽しみなのかもしれませんが
そうした楽しみを分かち合う喜びが
そこにあるからです
私は自分の寺で生まれ
高校を卒業するまで
自分の寺のある町で育ちました
大学進学や修行のために
８年間故郷を離れることになり
８年ぶりに帰郷した時には
ただ懐かしいというだけではなく
そう こう 何か激しい渇きにも似た
寂しさを感じて
自分の寺で働く傍らで
ただ がむしゃらに
そして様々なシーンで
自分の街に そして そこに住む人々に
関わってきました
そうした20代30代の過ごし方の中で
ますます私は自分の街が
大好きになり
ますます そこに暮らす人々が
40歳で住職を迎えたときには
自分の街だけではなく
世界で一番喜んでもらえるお寺に
世界で一番楽しんでもらえるお寺を
作ることが私の使命だとさえ
思えるようになっていたんです
今の活動を支え
苦楽を共にする仲間の多くは
そうした私とまちづくりの中で
出会った人が多いです
まぁ こんな風に話してると
なんだかすごく こう自信満々
順風満帆に聞こえるかもしれませんが
実はそうでもありません
結構うまくいかないこともあります
時には心に憂いや迷いが
生じないわけでもありません
そうした時に私を励まし
また 前へ前へと
進めてくれるものがあります
それが今 活動を共にする仲間たちから
聞くことができる
「ありがとう」という感謝の言葉や
「楽しい」という喜びの言葉なんです
そう 私は大丈夫
まだまだやっちゃえる
そんな風に思えるのは
この言葉のおかげかもしれません
法多山で毎年開催されているイベントに
コトコト市というものがあります
十数年の長きに渡って行われ
この地域のコミュニティマーケットの
草分け的存在のイベントです
その主催者の方から
「もし あなたのお寺でコトコト市を
引き受けてくれなかったら
こんなに長くは続かなかったでしょうし
それに この地域に人が集って
マーケットを開催する文化も
根付かなかったかもしれません
本当にありがとうございます」
という感謝の言葉を
毎回毎回いただきます
また私の友人で
街づくりや 今行っているお寺作りとは
何の縁もない仕事の人間なんですが
40歳過ぎてなんだかつまらないというので
私たちの活動に誘った男がいます
実は 今年の夏も
うちのお寺で開催された
お化け屋敷の設営を
夜遅くまで２人でやっていた時に
彼が突然に「あー やばい」って
言い出したので
「どうした 何か失敗した？」って聞くと
「うー 楽しくてしょうがない」
（笑）
「ここに人が入って
ドキドキワクワクするかと思うと
楽しくてしょうがない
50歳近くになって
こんなに楽しい想いができると思わなかった
誘ってくれてありがとう」
そんな彼の言葉を聞いて
少しうるっときてしまいました
今の活動や取り組みに対して
素晴らしい 斬新だ
そうした賞賛の声も確かに嬉しいんですが
それ以上に 活動を共にする仲間たちから
聞くことができる
ありがとうという感謝の言葉や
楽しいという喜びの言葉は
私の何よりの励みになっています
さて もうそろそろ皆さん
お気づきかもしれませんが
なぜ 私がこうした取り組みをしているのか
今 言った理由以前に
私が大好きなんです
私が
人が集ってにぎやかで
楽しいお寺が大好きなんです
確かに
お寺という空間は
静かで神聖であるべきだ
という方もいらっしゃると思います
またそういうお寺のほうが好きだよ
という方もいらっしゃるかもしれません
静かな空間 といえば
中に誰もいなくて こう
しーんとした状態のことを
「がらーんとした」とか
「がらんどう」と言いますよね
この「がらんどう」という言葉なんですが
漢字で書くと
「伽藍」と「堂」
そうなんです
これ実はどちらも
お寺のお堂を指す言葉なんですね
建物を指す言葉なんです
まぁ このお寺のお堂の中
普段誰も居なくてしーんとしてますよね
そうした状態が この「がらんどう」の
語源だと言われています
確かにお寺の本堂なんかは 普段は
何もなくて中ががらーんとしてますよね
もちろん これは ご本尊様を
お祀りする大切な空間ですし
様々な儀式にも使われますから
普段はがらーんとしていて
当たり前なんですが
それでも私はやっぱり賑やかで
楽しいお寺が大好きなんです
それに お寺の中でも
静かであるべき場所が
静かであればいいと私は思っているんです
私はこう考えます
お寺は仏様のため
だけの場所ではない
お寺は亡くなった方のため
だけの場所でもない
お寺は今生きている人のためにも
そしてそんな人々のためにも
あるべき場所なんです
それに 最初に言いましたが
お寺 全国で７万７千もあるんですよ
東京のど真ん中にも
田舎の村にも
ですから その場所にあった
お寺の活用方法というのが
必ずあると思うんです
例えば
大都会の真ん中に
緑豊かなオアシスを
出現させることだってできます
例えば ホールのない
田舎の小さな集落で
ジャズライブだってできちゃいます
今 全国のお寺が少しずつですが
変わろうとしています
かつて そうであったように
そこの地域コミュニティの拠り所として
そこに暮らし生きる人々のための場所として
でも 私のお寺がそうであるように
お寺だけが頑張ってもだめなんです
皆さんの力が必要なんです
この際です
皆さんの持っているお寺のイメージ
がらっと変えちゃいましょう
聖書の一節に
（笑）
「叩けよさらば開かれん」
という言葉があります
いや 仏教徒の私がそういう言葉
引用してはいけないのかもしれませんが
それでも もし
そこにお寺があったら
勇気を持って
その門をくぐってください
そこに新しい楽しみが
あるかもしれません
そこに あなたの知らない喜びが
少なくとも うちのお寺は大歓迎です
どうぞ いらしてください
そして私たちと一緒に
新しい楽しみを
まだ知らない喜びを
共に作っていきましょう
（ 拍手 ）